all right so in the last video we were
taking a look at this multiple choice
question from the ap us history exam
practice booklet and trying out some
strategies for making good choices as
you go through these questions the first
thing we did was really dive into the
specifics of what was happening in both
of these quotes
who james henry hammond is he's a
governor of south carolina who was in
favor of slavery in the mid 19th century
who is giving some religious reasons and
reasons of kindness for why slavery was
a institution sanctioned by god in
society and frederick douglass famous
abolitionist who's saying that slavery
is the great sin and shame of america so
our first step was analyzing the
documents
and then our second step was to read
each of our questions really carefully
and
both the questions and the possible
answer choices you need to give them
your full attention because you might
skip over an important word that makes
the meaning different than what you
thought it was at first glance the third
thing we're doing is going through each
of the options
and deciding whether or not it's a
possible before eliminating it so let's
try an example of a multiple choice
question related to these documents the
language used in both excerpts most
directly reflects the influence of which
of the following so they're specifically
asking us about
the language that means the words that
they're using their phrases not maybe
their political positions or
the ideas that they're trying to get
across but specifically the words and
we're looking for the influence
of one of these four ideologies okay
option a the second great awakening hmm
all right well i'm gonna
say that's a religious movement of some
kind and they both talk about god and
the relationship between slavery and
christianity so i'm going to leave that
as a possible all right what about
states rights well i imagine that both
these people would have had very
different ideas about states rights but
i'm not sure that's what they're talking
about in these examples because hammond
is talking about the duty of slave
owners to be kind and maybe the
religious reasons why god has made the
institution of slavery in his opinion
and douglas is talking about how slavery
is against the bible and against the
idea of liberty so
neither of them is particularly
concerned with the political issue of
states rights here so i think we can
cross that one out
all right manifest destiny
manifest destiny was this idea that the
united states had a divine mission to
occupy the north american continent from
atlantic to pacific
while they both kind of talk about ideas
of divinity uh i don't think they're
interested in any kind of pioneering
right um this is more connected to the
american west
than it is to
any idea about slavery so i think we can
get rid of that all right option d
american nationalism well i think
douglas is if anything he's kind of
saying that slavery challenges american
nationalism well i guess he talks about
it then maybe a nationalist view of the
idea of liberty would say that slavery
is a sin and a shame so that's that's
possible for douglas but what about for
hammond he's really making cultural and
religious arguments for slavery not any
argument about how slavery enhances the
american nation so i'm gonna cross that
one out too so that leaves us with the
second great awakening and i think that
is a good answer because both of them
are making religious arguments they're
saying that god would have liked or
would not have liked slavery so their
language does reflect an interest in
religion
we'll do some other examples in other
videos but i think the big takeaway from
this is don't worry about having every
idea and every fact about american
history store it away in your brain
somewhere instead understand that what
this exam is really going for is finding
out whether you have a good overall idea
of what happened in american history and
who might have supported which idea and
trust your instincts they're usually
right the point is not to test you on
some obscure outlier but rather to get a
sense that you know what you're talking
about in each era of history and
the general idea of what was going on so
use that to your advantage understand
the big underlying themes
and don't worry about the little ticky
tack details
you know what you're doing